madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
décidément cela ne s'arrange pas la
météo de votre week-end c'est encore du
froid de la neige et du verglas
une vague de froid comme on en a
rarement connu dans cette région il y
avait bien longtemps que la loire
n'avait charrie autant de glaçons hervé
marie place à leur tour aura été de
courte durée
les masses d'air froid venu du nord-est
ont inversé la tendance à la hausse du
thermomètre
et cela devrait durer au moins jusqu'à
mercredi selon les prévisions de la
météo nationale
conséquence du froid la loire envahi par
les glaces on n'avait pas vu cela depuis
une vingtaine d'années trafic fluvial
interrompue en amont nantes les bacs du
pèlerin et de basse-indre ne fonctionne
plus sur les routes la circulation reste
dangereuse et la nuit s'annonce
difficile pour les chauffeurs routiers
en particulier autorisés à rouler pour
rentrer chez eux ou assurer les
livraisons prioritaire mais qui devront
affronter brouillard givrant et verglas
un vrai temps de chien
mieux vaut rester chez soi oui les
températures relevées aujourd'hui à 13
heures était partout inférieures à zéro
degré dans la région